now I want to introduce a new idea and
that is the idea of voltage or current
some electrical signal being a function
of time cosine of Omega T so here what
we're doing is we're introducing time as
the argument to a cosine and time is
that stuff that always goes up this is a
number that increases forever
and we have another variable in here
called Omega this is the Greek lowercase
Omega and Omega it has an important job
in this the argument to cosine whatever
is inside the cosine
this has to be dimensionless this has to
have no units and so if we put in a unit
of seconds that means Omega is something
that has the units of 1 over seconds or
1 over time so Omega is 1 over time and
when we multiply those two numbers
together we get something that has no
units and then we can take the cosine of
it so this is referred to as a frequency
something that has units of 1 over time
is a frequency this is a constant number
this is some number this is a number
time is the number that increases all
the time and so when we have that cosine
we now have something we call a cosine
wave or a sine wave or a sinusoidal
time increases it keeps going and going
and going so now we've turned our our
trigonometric cosine function which is
right here which is something that was
well defined between zero and two pi
radians
notice that I've changed the axis the
axis is now in time over here and now
we're counting off time in seconds
there's two seconds three four or five
and that dot there that's at PI seconds
and this is at 2 pi seconds right that
dot right there and you can see that
that is the full
cycle of 1/cosine before it starts
repeating again so that's six point two
eight seconds so for this image here
Omega has the value of one so when when
time T reaches two PI seconds we've gone
through one full cycle so this idea of
this continuously changing cosine or
sine wave going on forever
that gives us the term sine wave and
sine waves are a good model for a lot of
things that happen in nature if you ever
hear a pure tone or a pure note a Bell
being rung or a whistle or if you sing a
note the shape of those tones looks like
a sine wave or a cosine wave and these
are often the things that come into our
electronic systems and we want to do
things with them so now I want to talk a
little bit more about the details of
this this kind of a sinusoidal earn some
new words for this
so one important concept is the idea of
any any repeating waveform any repeating
signal is the idea of a period let's
just do the zero crossings here if I
take the time change from there to there
this is the repeating interval of this
this function and I'm going to call that
that distance right there this is the
period of this sine function this this
is actually a cosine wave the period of
the sine is this distance in time right
here and the symbol we use is typically
a capital T to indicate the period so
let's look at this this cosine wave this
this sinusoidal II if I go right here it
looks like it repeats on this interval
right here every time we hit one of
those points so this would be if this is
time zero here this is time Big T this
is time 2 T on and on like that and I
read off this graph and what I see right
here is that the time is T equals 0.02
seconds so that's how you find out what
the period of something is you can take
any two points we could actually go
right here and then go through one cycle
and go to right here and I can read off
that period there there's T and that's
the same value as that T right over
there so the time T we can also call
that a cycle that's the time it takes to
go through one period that's one cycle
so one of the questions I can ask about
this waveform is how many cycles fit in
one second how many cycles per second is
another way to say that so we can say
that one cycle happens every T seconds
and in our particular case it's one
cycle per 0.02 seconds and if we take
the reciprocal of point zero two we get
the answer to be that's 50 cycles per
second that's the speed that's the
that's the repetition rate of this
sinusoidal is per second and this has
another name it's named in honor of a
German scientist and this is called a
Hertz Heinrich Hertz is the first person
to send a radio wave and receive it on
purpose he knew what he was doing we
named the unit cycles per second in his
honor and that's called the Hertz so now
we have two ways to measure frequency
one is F which is frequency which is
measured in Hertz
and that's cycles per second
and that one cycle equals two pi radians
per second so the two measures are
cycles per second and radians per second
and we'll flip back and forth between
those okay in radians per second or the
variable is omega and that's called
angular frequency or Radian frequency
and you'll sometimes see the word rad
used to indicate that we're talking
about angular or Radian frequency and
the variable is Omega so let's work out
what the relationship between F and
Omega it's actually sitting right here
okay so if I if I give you an F given F
what is Omega
so I write down a number F and it's in
cycles per second and I'm going to
multiply that by a conversion factor
that I'm going to make up so we're going
to multiply that by two pi radians per
second is the same as one cycle per
second
and that equals cycles per second
cancels with cycles per second so that
equals two pi F radians per second so
the conversion factor is Omega equals
two pi F and that's that's worth
remembering so if I have a sine wave a
voltage sine wave for instance V of T
equals cosine Omega T I can write that
equivalently as V of T equals cosine 2pi
f times T so one of the frequencies this
one is in cycles per second and this one
is in radians per second and we can
interchange them that way using this
conversion factor so if we take the
example from earlier in the video we had
a signal that was 50 Hertz or 50 cycles
per second so we would write that here
like this we'd say V of T equals cosine
2pi f and f is 50 times T and that's the
same as cosine of 100 by T so this
number right here 100 pi that's Omega
and this number right here is F so that
does it for our review of trigonometry
and we've introduced the idea of a sine
wave where T is the argument to the trig
function